AND JIMMY FAILLA.
THEY ARE AGAIN.
>> Jimmy: THERE IS OUR GUY.
>> Harris: WE THOUGHT THERE
WAS GOOD NEWS.
IT'S TEMPORARY.
RIGHT NOW THE NATION IS BRACING
FOR A RUSH AT THE BORDER STILL
WANTS TITLE 42 ENDS.
THE POLICY WAS SET TO END
TOMORROW.
THEN CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS
STEPPED IN, TEMPORARILY PUTTING
THAT ON HOLD.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
UNTIL 5:00 P.M. EASTERN TODAY TO
FILE A RESPONSE.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS IT HAS
DISPATCHED 23,000 BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND 1,000 PROCESSING CORE
NATIVE TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
WHILE THE TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD
DEPLOYED AN ADDITIONAL 400
TROOPS TO EL PASO.
BORDER AGENTS REMAIN OVERWHELMED
BY THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE FLOODING
INTO AMERICA.
MOST OF THEM UNVETTED AT THIS
POINT.
THIS IS A NEW VIDEO SHOWING A
LARGE GROUP OF PEOPLE SLEEPING
ON THE GROUND AT THE CITY'S
AIRPORT WAITING FOR THEIR
FLIGHTS.
SO "WE PROCESS THEM," AND THEY
FAN ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
BUT THAT INCLUDES BECAUSE OUR
MEN AND WOMEN OVERWHELMED.
THOSE ARE JUST THE PEOPLE WE
KNOW ABOUT.
I.C.E. HAS LOST TRACK OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND NOW THEY ARE
LEARNING MORE ON HOW THAT
HAPPENED.
THERE ARE ALREADY A MILLION OF
HERE.
FOX NEWS DIGITAL JUST OBTAINED
I.C.E. TRAINING VIDEOS FROM
NOVEMBER '21 TO FEBRUARY '22 AND
THEY REVEAL THE AGENCY WAS NOT
ABLE TO KEEP TABS ON PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S RELAX NO
PROCESSING IMMIGRATION POLICY.
STEAGALL FOR BACKGROUND ON THIS,
OVER THE SUMMER WE HAD WELL OVER
150,000 FOLKS COME IN.
THEY WERE ISSUED A PIECE OF
PAPER THAT SAID GO FIND SOMEBODY
IN I.C.E., AND THAT WAS PRETTY
MUCH IT.
THERE'S NO PROCESSING.
I KNOW THIS ISN'T SOMETHING YOU
ASKED FOR AND I ASSURE YOU THAT
NO ONE IN THE CRIMINAL ALIEN
PROGRAM ASKED FOR EITHER.
>> Harris: JUST IMAGINE HOW IT
WILL BE WHEN THE ENDS OF THE
FLOOD GATES ARE OPEN.
BY THE WAY, HE STARTED TO TELL
THE TRUTH ABOUT THINGS BEING
OPEN AT THE BORDER, THE
WHITE HOUSE SAYS YOU ARE HELPING
THE SMUGGLERS AND YOU ARE
AGAINST AMERICA.
>> Jimmy: IMAGINE.
AS IF THE PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY ARE SITTING AROUND
WATCHING CABLE NEWS ALL DAY.
THEY ARE NOT COMING BECAUSE WE
ARE TALKING ON CABLE, THEY ARE
COMING BECAUSE WE ARE LETTING
THE MEN.
JOE BIDEN HAS TURNED THIS
COUNTRY INTO THE COLLEGE BY THE
DOZEN CHECK I.D.
REMEMBER WHEN YOU WERE A YOUNG
KID IN THE WORD GOT OUT THAT
THERE WAS THIS ONE BAR NOT
ENFORCING PROCEDURES SO
EVERYBODY STARTED SHOWING UP?
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
THERE'S ALMOST A SOCIOPATHIC
INDIFFERENCE TO THE SUFFERING
THEY ARE CREATING AT THE BORDER.
NUMBER ONE, ITS HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
WOMEN CROSSING THE BORDER.
NUMBER TWO, YOU TALK ABOUT
FENTANYL BECOMING THE LEADING
CAUSE OF ADULT DEATHS IN THIS
COUNTRY, BUT THIS COMPLETELY
UNDERMINES THEIR PUBLIC HEALTH
INITIATIVES AS IT PERTAINS TO
COVID.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR A WORD
ABOUT GETTING VAXXED AND BOOSTED
IN GETTING A MASK, IF WE ARE
TAKING A DISEASE-SCREENING
MECHANISM ENTERING INTO THE
SIDE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DRAW
ATTENTION TO THE CRISIS.
IN HIS DEFENSE, WHEN THEY ASKED
HIM TO MAKE A RUN FOR THE
BORDER, HE DID THINK TACO BELL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Harris: TAMMY -- WOW, THERE
WAS A LOT THERE.
>> Tammy: HE HAS NO OPINION.
ONCE AGAIN, THE GUY HAS NO
OPINION.
>> Harris: PART OF THE COVID
ARGUMENT YOU ARE MAKING IS SO
EXCELLENT, BECAUSE THAT IS STILL
WHERE WE ARE.
YOU SEE AREAS THAT ARE
CONSIDERING TEMPORARY MANDATED
LOCKDOWNS OR MASK-WEARING.
I SHOULD SAY MORAL MASK-WEARING
THAN LOCKDOWNS AT THIS POINT.
WE ARE STILL IN SOME SORT OF AN
EMERGENCY WITH FLU, RSV -- WHAT
ARE THEY CALLING IT, THE
"TRIDEMIC?"
WE HAVE A DOCTOR ON THE COUCH
HERE.
>> Dr. Saphier: THERE ARE SOME
REPORTS
, AND I'M SURE DR. NICOLE CAN
SPEAK TO THIS, AS WELL.
THE FLU SEASON IS AVERAGE LIKE
IT WAS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC, NOT
THIS MONSTER THING THAT HAS BEEN
REPORTED.
BEYOND THAT, IT'S NOT JUST
COVID.
WE HAD THIS BEFORE.
ZIKA, MEASLES, TUBERCULOSIS, THE
PLAGUE.
A WHOLE HOST OF OTHER THINGS.
WHERE WE ARE MOST IN DANGER IS
WHERE WE WERE IN THE SUMMER-FALL
OF 2019 WHERE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WE ARE PREPARED FOR THESE
THINGS, WE HAVE TESTS, WE KNOW
WHERE TO LOOK.
THE QUESTION BECOMES, WHAT DON'T
WE KNOW?
WE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT ZIKA AND
THAT WAS AND IS A HORRIBLE THING
THAT NOW HAS MOVED FROM
SOUTH AMERICA UP INTO AMERICA,
AFFECTING FETUSES AND AFFECTING
CHILDREN, DEFORMING -- REMEMBER,
IT AFFECTED THE HEAD OF THE
LITTLE BABIES.
HORRIBLE THINGS GOING ON.
THE PLAGUE IS OUT THERE.
IT ALWAYS EXISTS, AND WE CAN
DEAL WITH IT.
BUT THAT IS WHAT TITLE 42 WAS
FOR.
AND IT'S NOT JUST A SURGE THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AND IS HAPPENING
THIS WEEK.
THAT'S BEEN THE INCENTIVE FOR
MONTHS.
SO IT IS THIS BACKUP AND
BUILD-UP, AND THOSE THOUSAND
PROCESSORS WHICH YOU TALKED
ABOUT IN YOUR INTRO, THEY ARE
REALLY JUST A PROCESS THEM.
THERE'S NOTHING GOING TO BE SENT
TO STOP THIS.
>> Harris: MORE OF THEM WILL
COME, KENNEDY, AND MORE WILL BE
ALLOWED TO STAY, BECAUSE THEY
ARE BRINGING IN PROCESSORS.
>> Kennedy: YEAH, THEY HAVE A
BIG RUBBER STAMPS.
THAT'S EXCITING.
[LAUGHTER]
THE ASYLUM PROCESS TAKES ABOUT
FIVE YEARS AND THAT'S UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT THE NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE
SEEN ARE VERY ABNORMAL.
THEY ARE TWO AND THREE TIMES
HIGHER THAN ANYTHING WE'VE EVER
SEEN.
SO IT'S IMPOSSIBLE, EVEN IF YOU
HAVE A THIRD MORE PROCESSORS
THEN YOU HAVE BEFORE, THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM IS OVERWHELMED.
IT'S A MASSIVE FAILURE OF
GOVERNMENT ON EVERY SINGLE
LEVEL.
NOT ONLY THE PRESIDENT, WHO IS
GASLIGHTING AND LYING TO ANYONE
WHO WILL ASK ABOUT THIS, WHETHER
THAT THREW HIMSELF OR THROUGH
HIS PRESS SECRETARY,
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE.
BUT IT'S THE ABDICATION OF
RESPONSIBILITY FROM CONGRESS AND
EVERY OTHER BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
THAT HAS WASHED THEIR HANDS OF
THIS PROBLEM.
WE SAW YESTERDAY, 500 PEOPLE
SLEEPING IN A ROOM THAT SHOULD
TAKE 100, WITH ONE BATHROOM.
SO THEY HATE PEOPLE WHO WERE
TERRIFIED AND IN PAIN AND THEY
ARE DOING NOTHING TO HELP THEM
EXCEPT LYING AND SAYING THE
BORDER IS SECURE AND THE
PRESIDENT IS WORKING.
>> Harris: AND THEY TRY TO
CANCEL LESS IF WE TELL THE TRUTH
ABOUT IT.
THAT'S WHAT THAT IS, IT IS
FURTHERING THE CENSORSHIP WE SEE
ON THE SOCIAL PLATFORM.
THEY JUST WANT TO STRAIGHT UP TO
IT TO OUR FACES.
>> Kennedy: THEY BRING BED
BUGS, LICE, CONSUMPTION, AND THE
VAPORS.
>> Jimmy: [LAUGHS]
>> Harris: TAMMY, IT'S
INTERESTING WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
BECAUSE TITLE 42 DID SO MUCH
MORE.
I WANT TO GET TO ART DEL CUETO
LAST HOUR ON
"THE FAULKNER FOCUS."
>> THE BORDER IS PRETTY MUCH
WIDE OPEN AND THERE SEEMS TO BE
NO CONSEQUENCES FOR INDIVIDUALS
ENTERING THE UNITED STATES RIGHT
NOW.
THIS ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO
REALIZE AT THE PROBLEM NOT JUST
FOR THEIR OWN POLITICAL AGENDA,
BUT A PROBLEM FOR EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE THIS
GOVERNMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ACTUALLY START
TAKING CARE OF THE PEOPLE, PUT
ASIDE THEIR HATRED FOR THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION, AND REALIZE THEY
ARE DOING MORE HARM TO AMERICANS
RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: THAT'S WHERE I WANT
TO GO WITH YOU,
DR. NICOLE SAPHIER.
WHEN YOU HATE THE LAST GUY
ENOUGH TO WANT TO HURT THE
FUTURE OF AMERICA, WHERE ARE
YOU?
>> Dr. Saphier: I WANT TO GO
BACK TO WHAT YOU STARTED WITH,
WHAT THE PRESS SECRETARY SAID.
SHE SAID ANYONE SAYING THERE IS
CHAOS OF THE BORDER, OR THAT
THERE WILL BE CAST WITH THE
REMOVAL OF TITLE 42, OR SAYING
THE BORDERS OPEN, THAT YOU ARE
ESSENTIALLY WORKING FOR
SMUGGLERS, THAT YOU ARE AN AGENT
OF MISINFORMATION.
WHAT AN IMPORTANT THING TO SAY
AND HOW DISRESPECTFUL THAT IS TO
OUR BORDER PATROL, TO THE
CIVILIANS WHOSE LIVES HAVE BEEN
UPENDED BECAUSE OF THE FAILURE
OF GOVERNMENT AND THE CATS
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
THEY HAVE ZERO RESPECT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEIR
CONDESCENSION IS SO PERMEABLE.
YOU CAN JUST -- IT'S TANGIBLE,
IT'S AWFUL WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WITH TITLE 42 RIGHT NOW, ANYONE
OTHER THAN MEXICANS CAN COME IN
THROUGH OUR BORDER SEEKING
ASYLUM WHETHER THEY REALLY NEED
ASYLUM OR NOT.
IF TITLE 42 IS REMOVED, EVERYONE
INCLUDING THE 2 MILLION MEXICANS
WHO WERE DENIED ENTRY OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS UNDER TITLE 42
ARE THEN ABLE TO COME.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE HAD COMPLETE
GOVERNMENTAL CONTROL FOR THE
LAST TWO YEARS, THEY'VE DONE
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
IT'S A CRISIS AT THE BORDER NOW
AND THE REPUBLICANS ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO STEP UP AND DO
SOMETHING, BECAUSE IT IS A
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
>> Harris: I DO WANT TO GET TO
THIS BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE
STARTING TO SPEAK OUT.
AND WILLIAM HURT WE KNOW AS A
CONGRESSMAN FROM TEXAS,
FORMERLY.
HE HAD A LOT TO SAY.
HE WAS TWEETING THIS YESTERDAY,
THAT OBAMA DEPORTED 3 MILLION
MORE FOLKS THAN TRUMP.
HE DIDN'T USE TITLE 42.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CAN
INCREASE EXPEDITED REMOVALS, THE
FANCY TERM FOR DEPORTING, USING
EXISTING -- ACTUALLY IT'S TITLE
EIGHT, HE DIDN'T GET THAT
RIGHT -- BY AUTHORITIES.
IT ISN'T THE ISSUE.
IT'S THE ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE
CRISIS AND THE WILL TO ENFORCE
OUR LAWS.
TITLE EIGHT, KENNEDY.
>> Kennedy: IT ALLOWS FOR SO
MUCH MORE IN THE LINES OF
DEPORTATION.
YOU CAN DO IT FOR CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY.
IT'S A LONG LIST.
THEY COULD GET AWAY WITH 42 AND
EFFECTIVELY GO TO SOMETHING EVEN
MORE POWERFUL.
YOU THINK THEY'LL DO IT?
>> Kennedy: THEY WON'T DO IT,
AND THEY WON'T OUTLINE WHO THEY
WANT IN THIS COUNTRY AND WHO
THEY WANT TO STAY OUT OF THIS
COUNTRY, AND THOSE ARE TWO VERY
IMPORTANT LISTS.
WE WANT PEOPLE HERE WHO ARE
GOING TO WORK HARD, ADD TO THE
ECONOMY, MAKE THE COUNTRY
BETTER.
WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO COMMIT VIOLENT CRIMES,
WHO ARE ENGAGED IN GANG
ACTIVITY, AND WHO ARE GOING TO
ACTIVELY HURT PEOPLE AND MAKE
THE COUNTRY WORSE.
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
WHO YOU WANT AND WHO YOU DON'T.
>> Harris: I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU DO THAT WITH THESE NUMBERS.
LAST THOUGHT, JIMMY?
>> Jimmy: THE K-TRAIN IS
RIGHT.
THERE IS THIS REAL INDIFFERENCE
TO THE WELL-BEING OF EVERYONE ON
EVERY SIDE OF THIS.
WOMEN COMING TO THIS COUNTRY ARE
GETTING SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ABOUT
30% OF THE TIME IF THEY ARE
COMING IN ILLEGALLY.
PEOPLE ON THE SIDE OF THE BORDER
ARE BEING KILLED.
BUT THE POLITICS FOR THEM ARE
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
PROTECTING HUMANS, BUT
PROTECTING THEMSELVES.
>> Tammy: AND WE HAVE BECOME A
PARTICIPANT IN THE TRAFFICKING
OF CHILDREN WHO ARE NOW MISSING
AND WILL NEVER BE FOUND IN THE
MIDST OF THIS COUNTRY.
SHAME ON US.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO STOP
THIS.
>> Jimmy: IT'S DISGUSTING.
TO HER POINT ABOUT THE CHILDREN,
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY SHUT DOWN
THE GOVERNMENT OVER WHAT WAS
CALLED "KIDS IN